I grew up Mormon and Joseph Smith was
the author of a world view that I held
for most of my life he wasn't religious
but from a young age he showed himself
as a skilled treasure hunter Upstate New
York was a place where people hunted for
Treasure there was this culture of folk
magic and legends that led to the search
for riches and jewels that were
potentially buried by Spanish explorers
or pirates of the past or artifacts that
were hidden in Native American burial
mounds and their methods for hunting for
all this treasure were mystical and
magical they used Seer Stones crystals
rods all of this to help them locate
Buried Treasure and young Joseph Smith
was very caught up in this treasure
hunting craze I mean let's keep some
perspective in all of our research we
didn't find a single like document
showing that he actually found any
treasure but he managed to convey to the
people around him that he was an expert
treasure hunter using mythical methods